how do I build a custom machine learning
model on Google Cloud alright so you
want to build a model awesome sauce what
kind of data have you got images videos
[Music]
or maybe you're working with something
seriously cool like pictures of cats
wearing hats or videos of pandas doing
karate moves dump all that data into
cloud storage where it can hang out with
all the other data and gossip about
pixels looking better if your data is a
bit of a nerd and likes to be organized
into tables you could also drop it into
bigquery and watch it all get excited
about being quarried once your data is
settled in its new home it's time to
bring it to life with Vortex AI you can
create an automl model and watch it
learn and grow like a little AI Sprout
or if you're feeling fancy make your own
custom model like a boss and voila when
you're done you get an API endpoint link
to your model and it's ready to be used
in your apps